far and away their most complete effort so far
in this young season Jake Kel over the attacking
line throws it to the net a tip by rust is Stone
by for Balo and he does the backwards Superman
to keep it out as you see him tries to make
the initial pass Jake Sanderson gets a stick
on it but then Rusty's in front finds him 35
seconds on the power play for Ottawa CL Juda
chin and his shot Rises up over the net he'll
hustle to try to keep it alive and will kubik
looking cross ice knocked down by Carlson it
finds Shu he centers the buck it in they score
Ridley Greg at top the crease a power play goal
for Ottawa and they have the early lead Claud
Drew is going to get it going to watch on the
right of your screen he's got some space he's
going to take it and just he knows just throw
it in there he's got if he can get it past
Eric Carlson he know he's he has his teammate
in front all by himself for that Split Second
before Graves can come back net side two of the
three highest scoring active players against the
SS the other one Alex oet penguin's pressuring
here and a chance from rust was swatted on goal
cor pasalo the stop there's Crosby feeding
it up top to Graves drives a great save cor
pasalo and there's a look zipping it through
the seam shot on net big rebound got the SE
on his jersey after a four-year Hiatus
of a captain SE in Ottawa that of course
following the departure of Eric Carlson he
was traded to San Jose wju he's worn the
captain C before in Philadelphia over to
kachuck comes in shoots and scores Brady
kachuck slips it through jari and it's
two nothing from kachuck and I thought he
was going to try to go upstairs and just
fires this a little bit above the left p
had and it's just uh that's how it goes sometimes
right like you get looks you don't bury it and
then Kelly out the center Sid going down to the
trademark one knee Gil back in a shot is stopped
by corpas solo it's loose they're whacking at
it and Corpus solo has been the story here in
the first keeps it out donor cor pasalo is coming
up big and this is the opportunity by Jake gensel
off the toe and then crash the net Pon in his
own head over skates jaru in Fr wrists it just
wide now the pens will look to go the other way
plenty of time to work with rust over the line
back door to gel drives it in a save P pasalo
gel with it again nice pass to Graves he'll
shoot save for Balo it's loose pinballed around
they whack for it and it would not go from Russ
getting over to gel gets a quick shot Corp
Solo's there and then it's just another shot
by Graves he's had a few and that Puck's just
rattling around in there so it's not going to
get any easier for the pens but they'll keep
hitting chances they dominated that first
period second period underway as the penguins
look to chip away at this two nothing deficit
kachuck finding Sanderson slips behind the goal
Jake Sanderson so smooth to hamic drives it in
scores it was tipped in front but
it gets past jari and Tra HCK Let
it Fly it's 3 nothing Ottawa sanderson's
all over the place with that skating and
actually not sure what this hits as
Sanderson gives it back hammeck fires
it let's give us a good angle right here as it
goes through and it does that hit off of graves
skate whatever it is boys left it open and ruers
peing what do you see I see an old iPad that's
not clear enough for us to see from here fair
enough I think the NHL needs to upgrade for the
the newer models so we'll hand it down to our
referee that's Cory sett with the announcement
down at ice level after video review could you
please reset the clock to 1607 the play was
offside no goal rolls out the [Applause] center
kubik doubles it ahead for Joseph he's over the
line comes to KUB drives it scores first
of the year for Dominic kubalik 3 nothing
Ottawa getting above them is you see Eller
kind of gives kubalik a bump and it's great
now but then kubik jumps around him and gets
going and creates an odd man rush out of
this no stick for Brian rust Sanderson trying
to work that to the advantage of the Senators
it comes across HCK rers blocks save hellberg and
somehow that did not go in bouncing around around
the goal watched by Norris Drew o Conor turns
throws it on goal save cor pasalo Eller in front
Court O Conor it wouldn't go Crosby to attang
finds rust looking shooting and a blocker save
by cor pasalo Ryan Graves to ATT tank for Russ
back door deflected in they score Sydney Crosby
finishes it off and the Penguins with a surge
late in the second have pushed themselves back
into this game it's 3-1 this might have to come
from him and I love the passing zip it around seen
passes Rush going and there's that trademark
we talked about it before that dropping to a
knee when Sid drops down like that he's doing
it because if that doesn't hit his stick it's
going to hit his skate and angle in his right
foot but he's so good at opening up his stick
play penguins with 86 shots on goal in
the third this year that is the second
most in the NHL they look to put some shots
towards the net and some in the net Marcus
Pon pressured by ro chartier a turnover
and a save by hellberg it's still loose
Shier curls it on that great stop hellberg
with the left toe about a minute and a half
for Carlson and peton as a centering
pass goes through everyone jaru back
down low kachuck gets to stla his Snapper
hellberg to save K Chuck on the backand
scores and Ottawa gets some insurance late
and the mountain gets that much higher for
the Penguins a buckle decor with Pon and Carlson
they've been out there for like you mentioned
Josh quite some time Brady kachuck able to take
advantage as he collects this off his skate look
at the patience just pulling it getting it around
Patterson and throwing that backand on net past
[Applause] hellberg Ottawa Senators
coming into tonight had also lost
three straight now they're up 4-1 six and
a half to go L tang in the attacking at a
pass knocked off Malin stick and look out
here comes Drake bson pass the defense Bon
scores and some salt in the wound
now 5-1 [Applause] Ottawa getting
Off to the Races as you see a shot
trying to go through and nice heads
up play head Manning the park to
bson who goes backhand off the
post this is one of those one of those frustrating
games I do think this line though still had a we
talked about the Yer look out stoin for great
save help ber on the tap by jeru swerves his way
through Center and Over The Line a pass for Crosby
is knocked Away by baon Chad ridle to it sends it
right back into the attacking end Crosby with it
for gel he'll rip it [Music] scores well that's
199 for Jake gensel and a bit of personal silver
lining 5-2 another seam pass here Crosby's going
to get it right through to Jake who's setting up
collects it goes Far [Applause] Side shoots this
one right past Jake Sanderson and as the Ottawa
Senators race out to a three- nothing lead and
they take care of the pens by a final score of
5-2 here at PPG Paints Arena so rer not a great
start for the Penguins as far as the goals
against as you mentioned as the game wore on